I'm very grateful to Judy and the other
administrators at the Radcliffe
Institute for their benevolent guidance
throughout the year to my fellow fellows
for their inspiration and the stimulus
that they provide to my research
partners for their youthful energy and
enthusiasm and I just want to say it's
been a fantastic experience doing human
rights at Harvard I think there's
probably no better place to investigate
human rights and it's been wonderful
interacting with some people that I
regard as my heroes in this subject
it's invidious to name individuals but
I'll just go right ahead and do that the
great Amartya Sen John Ruggie Charles
freed Jerry Newman and of course
Katherine sinking who's my fellow also
at the Radcliffe Institute Ben people
whose work I've long admired and it's
been a tremendous privilege to be able
to interact with them and discuss with
them on the topic of human rights so the
talk I'm going to give today actually
has a slightly modified title from the
one advertised it's Human Rights three
questions and I hope we will actually
get to the third question so let's begin
one of my favorite remarks about
philosophy comes from would the Vidkun
Stein Wittgenstein said it's difficult
to begin at the beginning and not to try
to go further back where should we begin
when it comes to the philosophical
reflection on human rights the place to
begin I think is not philosophy itself
but what we might call the practice of
human rights the role that the idea of
human rights plays in the lives of
ordinary human beings and in the
cultures and institutions that they
sustain some of this practice is
crystallized in authoritative documents
such as the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights and the many legally
binding and treaties that have followed
in its wake some of the practice
concerns the activities of institutional
structures among them States
international organizations and
liberation of NGOs nongovernmental
organizations but the important thing to
stress is that the practice has a life
beyond formal documents beyond laws and
institutions but as a foothold in a
deeper culturally embedded self
understanding one that ordinary
individuals can draw on in order to
formulate their aspirations and to give
point to their criticisms of injustice
and oppression so my book begins by
reflecting on this practice of human
rights not from some ethereal
philosophical space signing bid contain
I said the problem is to avoid going
further back what would it mean to go
further back well one way to begin too
far back is to begin from a
philosophical theory of ethics and by a
theory of ethics I mean an attempt to
systematize ethics ideally by reducing
it to a single master principle I think
theory is the wrong place to begin for
two reasons the first is there's no
reason to suppose that starting from
their human rights as we normally
understand them will ever come into view
we will change the subject or distort
the subject and it's not obvious why
someone not already committed to the
theory should be interested in an
engaged or distorted reflections of this
sort now of course the proponents of
theory have a quick answer to this
objection they say that their theory
embodies the truth about ethics
therefore to the extent that ordinary
human rights thinking is sound it must
be congruent with the theory but the
problem is that it's very doubtful that
any existing theory captures the truth
about ethics and that's not because
there is no such thing as s it ethical
truth but because that truth is arguably
not amenable to systematization it does
not flow from a single fundamental
principle instead it requires us to take
into account a plurality of quite
distinct values and to exercise judgment
in discerning their practical
implications as the British moral
philosopher Bernard Williams disarmingly
put
perhaps we need as many concepts to
describe the ethical truth as we find we
need and no fewer I would go further not
only do we need multiple value concepts
we also need multiple methods for
exploring and deploying those concepts
philosophy with its stress on abstract
and discursive reasoning is just one
method but there are many other methods
for example forms of literary fiction
that bring out the significance of ideas
such as the dignity of the individual
through the emotionally resonant
description of particulars even if I
wouldn't go so far as Lin Hunt the
intellectual historian who has argued
that the novel was the key to the
invention of human rights in the 18th
century but that's partly because I
doubt the coherence of saying that human
rights were invented finding a more
perspicuous way of talking about
something is not the same thing as
inventing it
so philosophy is one way of trying to
make sense of the practice of human
rights to understand it to evaluate it
but it's Authority doesn't come from
mobilizing a pre-existing theory so
insofar as it has any claim to our
attention it comes from the fact that
philosophers have been given the leisure
to address this topic in a more
sustained way than many others as Judy
pointed out some of us are paid to do so
and from the virtues of clarity and
rigorous argument that philosophers are
supposed to cultivate but which of
course are not unique to philosophy so
the three questions that I want to
discuss today are certainly questions
for a philosophy of human rights but
they are not exclusively philosophical
questions they are questions for anyone
who takes the practice of human rights
seriously and there are many different
routes for getting at the truth about
these questions and particularly
resistant to calling them philosophical
questions because all too often in my
experience this is a rhetorical ploy
from
marginalizing questions we urgently need
to deal with marginalizing them by
associating those questions with the
activities of typically small and
marginal university departments now the
book that I'm engaged in writing is in
some sense landish in its scope and
ambition it tries to address some of the
most fundamental questions in the
philosophy of human rights the morality
of human rights all the way to quite
deep and complicated questions in the
international law of human rights so
deep and complicated that they're below
the pay grade of most international
lawyers at least practicing
international lawyers so you might think
that any book that attempts within its
covers to cover all of that material is
a kind of fool's errand but it's April
Fool's Day so I think what what better
what better days to try to talk about
this quixotic endeavor of mine so let me
briefly introduce these three questions
and then I'll look into the three of
them in greater detail and give you the
shape of the answer that I'm groping
towards in my book so first the first
question is the question of the nature
of human rights what are we talking
about when we refer to human rights what
distinguishes the set of standards for
governing this set of standards for
governing human conduct from other
standards we might recognize for example
standards of justice or fairness
efficiency or plain old obligations now
may be different people mean different
things by human rights that's probably
true but it still makes sense to ask
whether there is a core concept of a
human right one that is central to
understanding the practice of human
rights other concepts would be parasitic
or peripheral in relation to this core
concept so what's the nature of human
rights first question the second
question what is the ground of human
rights even if we agree on what human
rights are supposed to be how can we
determine whether there are any human
rights consider an analogy we might
agree on what we mean when
refer to unicorns or witches but it's a
further question whether any exists now
at least one prominent philosopher
Alistair McIntyre before he recanted
but anyway claimed that human rights are
like witches in unicorns purely
fictional entities since no good reason
has ever been given for believing in
their existence can this skepticism be
countered by offering grounds for
affirming the existence of human rights
that's the question of grounds third
question a bit more nebulous
less shaped to it but I call it the
question of the force the force of human
rights in practical deliberation this is
a many-sided question but one way of
bringing out what I'm concerned with
here is in terms of the idea of conflict
human rights entering into conflict it's
often said that human rights conflict
among each other
one person's right to privacy can
conflict' with another person's right to
security more commonly it's said that
human rights often conflict with the
public good or with general welfare so
for example it said we respect the
rights to due process of criminal
suspects even if we know that by
violating those rights we could better
secure the general good should we think
of human rights are systematically
entering into conflicts with each other
and with the common good I think that's
a profound error I'll come back to this
question of the force of human rights
later so let's begin then with the first
question what are we talking about when
we talk about human rights what is the
nature of human rights now the idea of
human rights has come into the
prominence since the Second World War
but they remain a focus or a locus of
disagreement some people are skeptical
that there are any human rights others
disagree about which rights exist some
believe that civil and political rights
such as the right to a fair trial or not
to be tortured are genuine human rights
but that socio-economic rights such as
the right to work or to health what an
adequate standard of living are not
genuine human rights but if we truly
disagree in these ways
we must at least agree on what we mean
by human rights otherwise these would be
merely verbal disagreements we'd be like
people disagreeing about banks where one
has in mind financial institution and
the other the sloping bits of land on
the sides of rivers so even those who
disagree about human rights must share a
concept of a human right that makes that
disagreement possible but what is that
concept now in my book I elaborate on
and defend what I call the Orthodox view
of human rights now that's a view that
up until now has been widely subscribed
to if only as a slogan rather than a
properly worked out position and the
Orthodox view can be formulated in this
familiar way human rights are moral
rights possessed by all human beings
simply in virtue of their humanity human
rights and moral rights possessed by all
human beings simply in virtue of their
humanity in other words for short human
rights are universal moral rights so
let's break down this idea into two
parts on the one had moral rights and on
the other hand possessed by all humans
simply in virtue of their humanity human
rights according to me and this Orthodox
view our moral rights in the sense that
they are rights that exist as a matter
of what is morally true justified
correct now the crucial point I want to
stress is to say that someone has a
right is to say that they have an
entitlement that places a duty on others
if I have a right not to be tortured
it's not just the case that others have
a reason not to torture me that it would
be good if I wasn't tortured or somehow
beneficial if I wasn't tortured instead
it's to say something further there
others have a moral duty or an
obligation not to torture me and one
implication of this is that if they fail
to act on that Duty they should feel
guilty rightly they may properly be
blamed by others the victim may properly
feel resentment and in some cases there
may be consequent obligations to
compensate the victim
inflict punishment on the rights
violator
so human rights are not merely a
shopping list of goods that it would be
desirable to secure to people instead
they have a graver
import they impose duties on us which
render us morally blameworthy if we
violate them that is the powerful
critical edge of human rights introduced
now there may be moral rights of
different sorts some moral rights I
possess because of something I've done
for example the right I have - a cup of
coffee every morning after handing over
money to Burdick's other moral rights I
had because I'm a member of a family or
some other community but some moral
rights I possess simply as a human being
irrespective of what I've done or what
other status I may possess such as a
friend or a teacher or a member of a
particular political community these
universal moral rights are human rights
and the further point to make is that I
possess these rights irrespective of
whether others including the law social
convention public opinion regards me as
possessing them I possess a human right
because there is a compelling moral case
for attributing it to all human beings
not because it's conferred by some act
of social Fiat so human rights are not
to be identified in the first instance
with human rights law on the contrary
it's the other way around the defining
point of human rights law is to give
content and force to the independent
morality of human rights that's what
makes human rights or gives it its
integrity as an area of law now if we
understand human rights in this Orthodox
way then they are strongly continuous
with what in former times were known as
natural rights we should we should then
see the contemporary human rights
culture as essentially about the same
topic as the natural rights tradition in
the 17th and 18th centuries in fact as
the great medieval historian Brian
Tierney has argued we could push this
even further back to the emergence of
natural rights in the writings of the
Canon Law
Lavanya in the 12th century personally i
think you could push even further back
to ancient greece now in recent years
thanks in large part to the influence of
the great harvard philosopher John Rawls
the Orthodox view of human rights has
come under severe attack the Orthodox
view according to Rawls overlooks the
fact that human rights are best
understood as having a political
function this prevents the Orthodox
account from making sense of the
practice of human rights now
philosophers who hold this political
view differ about what exactly the
political function that defines human
rights is worth sometimes a combination
of functions here I want to focus on one
widely cited function and it has two
dimensions
so the first dimension is that human
rights are political insofar as they
directly impose obligations on the state
or state like entities rather than on
individuals or private groups within the
state so they directly bind the state or
state like entities not individuals nor
private groups second human rights are
political insofar as the failure of the
state to comply with them is in
principle in principle a trigger for
international action so according to
Rawls who has the most stringent version
of this view what's distinctive about
human rights is that they are those
rights which are triggers for military
intervention so therefore he actually
comes up with a very very short list of
human rights because he quite reasonably
thinks that only a very short list of
bryant's could justify military
intervention now only half-jokingly I
call this the coercive intervention
account of human rights or c.i.a for
short
it indicates so it does have a wide
irrelevant resonance other philosophers
who adopt the political view conceive of
intervention more broadly they wouldn't
make military intervention such an
important criteria they would also say
things like economic sanctions or even
formal rebukes by one state by another
would count as a kind of international
action or intervention now the allure of
a political conception of human rights
is not confined to philosophers the
Harvard legal historian Samuel moines
has argued that human rights were really
born in the 1970s thanks to the Carter
Administration they are not essentially
natural rights and that's because only
in the 70s only in the 70s were human
rights viewed as triggers for an
international response in the event of
their violation now as a proponent of
the Orthodox view I don't deny the
obvious truth that human rights have
political functions but I do deny that
their nature is given by any such
function here's a comparison that
hopefully makes that distinction clearer
there's no doubt that nuclear energy has
political functions but you can
adequately grasp what nuclear energy is
without knowing anything about the
political uses such as being part of a
strategy of mutually assured destruction
to which nuclear energy can be put I
think the same is true of human rights
you can grasp what they are by knowing
that their universal moral rights
without knowing anything about the state
or about intervention or economic sense
Act sanctions or anything else these
things are relevant to how you might
implement human rights but they don't
define their essential nature so why do
I reject this political view that's
getting an enormous amount of traction
well let's go back to its two elements
first I want to resist the claim that
the primary or exclusive bearer of human
rights duties is the state I think it
makes better sense of human rights
practice to say that non-state entities
can bear human rights obligations so
here are two examples the first is the
example of a solar tree torturer the
solitary torturer
randomly adducts passes by and torches
them in his basement if we know that
this is what he's doing I think we can
immediately proceed to the conclusion
that he is violating their human rights
we don't need to ask is this man an
official of the state you see operating
with the connivance of the state were
able to do what he's doing only because
the state is not adequately meeting its
own human rights obligations to
eradicate torture and there was quickly
poignant experience I had once listening
to a talk by the UN Special Rapporteur
on torture he's in responsible for
overseeing the implementation of the
Convention Against Torture which is
limited to states and is limited to
States because it's a treaty and
treaties bind states that enter into
them and yet he said in his activities
he was in Earl actively involved in
non-state torture right and there you
see the contrast between the legal
situation which is it's about States but
the underlying moral situation is not
limited to States because the underlying
moral right is one that binds non-state
entities as well so it was interesting
to see him being sort of conflicted
about this but the conflict arose
precisely from the tension between his
legal responsibilities and the moral
concerned that those legal
responsibilities were meant to reflect
there is a broader feminist point here
as well to bear in mind they attempt to
limit human rights to the domain of high
politics or the behavior of the state I
think goes against the idea that often
in securing political values we have to
look at what happens in private realms
and here I would even quote the words of
Eleanor Roosevelt who was one of the
framers of Universal Declaration she
says what she said something to the
effect that human rights
begin in small places close to home I
think they actually can begin right in
the home not just close to home the
second example I want to give is the
2011 UN guiding principles on business
and human rights which were principally
authored by Harvard's John Ruggie
now these principles have been endorsed
by the UN the OECD the EU
and a variety of other bodies including
the American Bar Association and what is
crucial for our purposes is that they
directly impose human rights obligations
on corporations quite independently of
anything that the state is doing the
guiding principles are one of the most
important innovations in human rights
practice and they break decisively but
the status assumptions of the political
view that the primary or exclusive
bearer of human rights responsibilities
is the state moreover and this is really
crucial
rhaggy correctly emphasizes that
corporations do not have human rights
obligations because they're exercising
governance functions akin to the state
that's the last thing that we would want
I think is to have corporations going
around behaving as though they had the
authority of the state states have a
duty to promote human rights which
includes to do that by enacting laws
that bind other entities like
individuals and corporations but
corporations under the guiding
principles have a duty to respect human
rights themselves now as a philosopher
it's gratifying to me to see Ruggie in
his important book on the guiding
principles pay tribute to Amartya Sen
one of the leading proponents of the
Orthodox view of human rights what this
illustrates to me is that far from being
alienated from the contemporary practice
of human rights the Orthodox view is
actually at the heart of some of the
most important developments in the field
today so let me briefly turn to the
second component of the political view
remember the second component was what
happens when the state fails to meet its
human rights obligations answer in
principle these violations are a trigger
for an international response now the
most sophisticated deployment of this
view is to be found in a very careful
book called the idea of human rights
written by the Princeton political
theorist Charles bites bites argues that
human rights differ from other rights in
that their violation triggers
international concern but then as mark
of his intellectual courage he faces up
to the potentially alarming implications
of this view can
sitter as one example rights against
gender discrimination this is one of
these crazy philosophical thought
experiments on giving you the warning
now suppose overwhelming empirical
evidence was discovered that there was
simply nothing outside agents could do
to promote gender equality in Islamic
societies attempts to promote gender
equality are found to be systematically
ineffective or even counterproductive
insofar as they're seen as disrespectful
meddling
if this empirical finding were
well-established it would have the
upshot on biases political view that
gender equality could not be a human
right because it's violation could never
trigger effective international action
because there is no effective
international action one could take now
if you find that conclusion hard to
swallow I think it's because the
political view offers the wrong
characterization of what it is to be a
human right women have a right not to be
discriminated against because others
including the state they inhabit bare
obligations not to discriminate against
them it's a further question an
independent question whether or not
these obligations can be advanced by
means of international action now in
defending the Orthodox view I think
there's a broader lesson to be learned
and that is the importance of separating
out human rights as moral ideals from
any set of policies mechanisms or
institutions for giving effect to them
it's one question what human rights
essentially are Universal moral rights
if I'm right it's another vitally
important but nonetheless different
question how we best give effect to them
in any given point in history we best
preserve the integrity and critical
power of human rights discourse by not
conflating those two questions as the
political view tends to do I think this
is especially so when it comes to the
extremely contentious and problematic
policy of foreign intervention I don't
think it's very friendly to human rights
to tether that very concept to such a
fraught policy as one of foreign
intervention
particular military intervention so let
me shift now to the question of the
grounds of human rights and let me
introduce that question by quoting a
story told by Jacque Marita a well-known
Catholic philosopher from the middle of
the last century and this is the
quotation he says it is related that at
a UNESCO National Commission where human
rights were being discussed
someone expressed astonishment that
certain champions of violently opposed
ideologies had agreed on a list of those
rights
remember this is during the Cold War yes
they said we agree about the rights but
on condition that no one asks us why and
Meriton goes on to say that why that why
is where the argument begins now the why
question is the question of grounds what
makes it the case that something is a
human right a universal moral right now
if we agree on the human rights you
might reasonably ask whether we need to
bother about the question why we do so
now this question was pressed very hard
by the American pragmatist philosopher
Richard Rorty giving justifications for
human rights was perfectly appropriate
back in the 18th century brought he said
when they seemed radical unheard of
proposals but in our day
according to Rorty human rights command
far more agreement than anything we
might use to justify them therefore
trying to justify them is a pointless
and potentially counterproductive
exercise now there are many things wrong
with rotties view let me just mention
one of them Rory says we agree on the
human rights and it's true many of us
would come up with an almost identical
list of human rights rights with the
same names or labels such as a right not
to be tortured or privacy or free speech
but whether the lists
truly identical depends not on the names
but on the content of the rights on what
it is exactly that they entitled us to
what the duties are that are associated
with them and it's very doubtful that we
do agree on the content of Human Rights
a recent vivid example of disagreement
about content was the Bush
administration's rather creative
reinterpretation of the paradigmatic
human right the right not to be tortured
you may recall this was defined by
lawyers for the Bush administration as
damaged that rises to the level of death
organ failure or the permanent
impairment of a significant body
function but we also see disagreements
between American and European approaches
to free speech on matters such as
Holocaust denial or pornography so
Meriton was dead wrong to say that
disagreement only begins with the why
question moreover disagreements as to
content that I've been highlighting can
only be addressed by asking the why
question because it's only if we know
what makes something a human right that
we can begin to specify its content so
the why question can't be sidelined on
the basis that we all agree on what the
rights are so what are the grounds or
the foundations of human rights now in
answering this question the answer I
give to this question in the book
appeals to two intimately related
grounds often in philosophy people try
to single out one particular ground I
think this is a hopeless endeavor
both of these grounds have their
partisans but I think I actually have to
work together to make any sense the
first ground of human rights is what I
call universal human interests interests
are the elements of a good life the
fulfillment of which makes a person's
life better than otherwise it would be
now I don't elaborate a theory of
universal human interests in my book I
mean there's only so much of a fool's
errand I'm willing to undertake but I
draw on work that's been done in this
area by some of my former
at Oxford especially John finis and
James Griffin and they make it clear in
at least they make it clear to me that
there is an irreducible plurality of
human interests human well-being does
not boil down to one overarching
interest such as pleasure or the
avoidance of pain there is an open-ended
list of universal interests such as
knowledge accomplishment friendship play
and so on and the other point is that
the interests are objective the point
that a lot of people find very difficult
to swallow the interests are objective
they are interests of ours irrespective
of whether we believe them to be our
interests or whether we desire them so
there is a rich broad the Aristotelian
account of the human good at the basis
of human rights now even if there's a
plurality of interests some philosophers
and most prominent among them James
Griffin and Amartya Sen have argued that
human rights are ultimately derived from
one kind of interest are interested in
freedom are interested being able to
choose from a valuable array of options
and to pursue our choices without
interference from others so on this view
human rights are ultimately protections
of freedom which is one human good
amongst others it's wrong to say that
all human Goods play into the existence
of human rights now although it'd be
elegant to conclude that all human
rights serve one fundamental interest I
think this view comes at an excessive
cost there are three things I would
highlight if human rights of protections
of freedom humans without the capacity
for choice will lack human rights second
it just seems very odd even when we're
talking about fully competent adults
that human rights only protect freedom
you see this oddness in Griffin's
discussion of torture where he says
torture violates a human right because
it undermines our capacity to reach a
decision and stick to it as if the fact
that torture is bloody painful is
irrelevant to it being a human rights
violation as if the fact that torture
grossly corrodes our capacity for
friendship and attachment with others
and undermines our trust in others is
irrelevant
human rights violation the final thing I
would say is this in a world in which
human rights morality is constantly
subject to the objection that it's
another form of Western imperialism
reflecting Western bias in favor of
freedom as opposed to all other goods I
think we don't put ourselves in a good
position to counteract that objection by
saying that it's the only good that's
relevant to the justification of human
rights but I think that interests aren't
enough and the other ground that I
appeal to in the book is the idea of
equal human dignity so its interests and
dignity working together to justify
human rights the interests of the
interests of human beings to have an
inherent value simply in virtue of their
status as human beings we possess this
value because we belong to a species
with the nature of a certain kind most
centrally a rational nature we all
possess this value and to an equal
degree this is so even if in the case of
some individual humans this nature
cannot be fully actualized because
they're suffering for example from
senile dementia or some other such
condition so the second foundation is
the inherent value of being a human
equal human dignity now I say the two
grounds interests and dignity work
together in intimate alliance if you
didn't have dignity you'd be much more
liable to the utilitarian thought that
individuals are simply the location at
which interests are realized they'd be
little to stop you saying that you
should maximize the fulfillment of
interests by trading up some people's
interests against others they'd be
little to stop you saying that you
should torture one innocent person to
prevent five other innocent persons from
being tortured so though I accept the
idea of dignity is a rather difficult
intractable and nebulous concept I think
it's essential to appeal to it because
by emphasizing the irreducible value of
the individual you precisely erect some
kind of barrier or resistance to the
idea that you simply engage in the
process of maximizing interests across
all people people count intrinsically
and that's what the idea of human
dignity is bringing out so human rights
have a double foundation in dignity and
rights but they're not this interests
but they're not the same as dignity and
interests actions or attitudes that
contravene interests or dignity are not
necessarily human rights violations and
the reason for this was given earlier
because human rights violations involve
duties and it's not always the case that
action is inconsistent with others
dignity and interests are violations of
duties so let me give two examples you
beat someone fair and square for a job
that they covered the only job in
philosophy going this year you may have
impaired their interests arguably you
may have ruined their life but it
doesn't follow that you've done anything
wrong that you have violated a duty owed
to them the same analysis applies to
someone in dire need of a kidney
transplant you would be acting with
admirable charity if you donated your
spare healthy kidney but the failure to
do so is not a violation of the duty
owed to them the other doesn't have a
human right to your spare kidney that's
an example from interests but I think we
can equally come up with an example from
the side of dignity how disrespecting
dignity is not necessarily a human
rights violation
imagine someone I'll call a liberal
racist he has impeccably liberal beliefs
sincerely held yet because of the
conservative upbringing he might find
himself saddled with emotional responses
that are racist responses that are
rooted in the idea that say blacks do
not possess fully equal status with
whites he may even experience these
emotional responses with dismay as when
he's disappointed to find that the new
family moving next door is black and is
dismayed at his disappointment but it's
doubtful that such a response in and of
itself constitutes a human rights
violations although it's morally
reprehensible so in all these cases
there may be a setback to interests or a
failure to properly risk register and
equal human dignity but arguably at
least there is no rights violation and
the reason for this is that no duty was
clearly contravened in those cases at
least not one owed to someone as a
matter of right now thinking about why
there was no duty
leads us to one of the most difficult
questions in the philosophy of human
rights and that is how we get from the
underlying values which I'm suggesting
interests and dignity to the conclusion
that they generated duty to respect them
or protect them in various ways this is
a very complex question but I think I'll
just note two considerations that are
relevant that are called possibility and
burdensomeness two considerations
relevant to going from interest in
dignity to a duty so the first
consideration is possibility
there'll be no duty to do something if
it's not possible to do that thing the
self policing of immediate emotional
responses is something that is not
generally possible for us to achieve
hence the liberal racists emotional
responses are arguably not a violation
of Gd although they are morally
defective taking a more obvious example
there can be no human right to ensure
that everyone is an above-average
student because it's simply not
logically possible for all students to
be above average fans of Monty Python's
Life of Brian will also remember the
sophisticated discussion of a man's
supposed right to bear children also
ruled out on grounds of impossibility
this time biological so that's
possibility the other consideration
burdensomeness even if it were possible
for people to subject their emotional
responses to the necessary form of
self-policing it would be too burdensome
to demand this as a matter of duty just
as it would be too burdensome to impose
upon people the duty to furnish those in
need of a transplant with their spare
kidney although it would be morally
praiseworthy for someone to denote that
donate their healthy kidney they would
not be violating a right in failing to
do so and of course there are very
difficult questions here which costs
count towards burdensomeness so the fact
that pharmaceutical companies charged
like wounded bulls for drugs is not part
of the costs we need to factor in
because that's a product of a choice
they simply made but other costs do
factor in so I think philosophers have
been much exercised about finding the
Holy Grail v value protected by human
rights I think human rights protect an
array of values the much more difficult
question is
how do we get from those values to
detect something that has the shape of
the duty and that's something that we
haven't written really enough about or
grappled with sufficiently for the
obvious reason I think that it's too
hard
third and final question the question of
force what is the force of human rights
what's their role in practical
deliberation especially how should we
conceive of conflicts involving human
rights now often a focus for the topic
of force is the more specific question
whether there are any absolute human
rights in other words are there any
human rights of such surpassing weight
that it's never justifiable to violate
them irrespective of the cost now in one
way this question is easily answered
depending on how you specify the right
for example the right of people not to
be tortured simply for fun is obviously
an absolute one but of course it gets
far more complicated if we don't
introduce qualifications as to the
motive for torture another way in which
the issue of absolute rights is complex
is the need to draw a distinction
between human rights as a matter of
morality versus human rights as they
figure in law even if you conceded that
the moral right not to be tortured could
be overridden in very extreme cases it's
a further question whether the law
should reflect this possibility for
example if the law retd the right not to
be tortured is not absolute this might
have the unintended effect of actually
encouraging torture in cases where it
isn't justified and that illustrates the
broader theme that the road from the
morality of human rights to the morality
of the law of human rights is often a
long and winding one without shortcuts
but I want to accept that many if not
all human rights are subject to being
defeated or overridden the point I want
to make is that there is a tendency to
vastly exaggerate the extent to which
human rights come into conflict and a
subject to trade-offs either among
themselves or against other concerns
such as the common good
even if they're not immune to trade-offs
human rights are highly resistant to
them and I want to conclude with some
thoughts on why human rights are not as
readily liable to be defeated as we are
often led to believe they are by
philosophers lawyers and others so I'll
just highlight one of these reasons
because I'm conscious of time human
rights are not the same as the interests
they derive from there was a crucial
point I try to emphasize earlier instead
they enter into practical deliberation
not as interests but as duties deriving
from interests and equal status of
dignity once we see that human rights
involve duties then we're in a position
to resist the idea that they are
regularly subject to trade-offs because
it belongs to the idea of a duty that
it's resistant to trade-offs not
absolutely but generally so let me give
an example of one scenario that some
philosophers would say involves a
conflict of human rights Griffin says
this for example the case of a properly
convicted murderer who has been given a
just sentence of imprisonment the just
sentence is demanded by the fact that he
violated his victims right to life now
the philosophers I have in mind would
say that in in imposing the just
sentence we are justifiably violating
the murderers right to Liberty so the
claim is we have two things in the
balance in the one hand the just
sentence which reflects the right to
live a right to life of the victim and
on the other hand the right to liberty
of the murderer and the claim is that
the right to life of the victim has
reflected in the just sentence our ways
the right to liberty of the murderer and
justifies violating their right to
Liberty I think this way of looking at
the situation is profoundly mistaken the
murderers right to Liberty is not
violated not even justifiably violated
by the sentence of imprisonment
what is impaired by the sentence is the
murderers interest in
that's the point of punishment it's
supposed to inflict hard treatment on
wrongdoers
but the interest in Liberty is not the
same as the right to Liberty the right
to Liberty is determined by the extent
to which the interest generates a duty
and I think there is simply no duty to
allow a murderer to remain at large when
a just sentence requires that he be
imprisoned or put it another way the
just sentence does not defeat the
murderers right to Liberty instead the
right to Liberty is subject to
exceptions one of which is the demands
of just punishment so a situation where
someone's right to Liberty was really
overridden would be something like a
case of justified internment this is a
situation where the state imprisons
without trial
a large group of people many of whom the
state knows in advance are bound to be
innocent they can't identify which in
order to avoid some massive threat like
the bombing of a major city here their
right to Liberty really is justifiably
overridden and this is manifest in
various ways for example an innocent
member of this group
unlike the properly convicted murderer
would be justified in taking steps to
avoid internment moreover unlike the
properly convicted murderer innocent
people subject to imprisonment in these
situations would be owed an apology and
perhaps even compensation after the
event these are markers of the
obligation that was overridden
even though justifiably so and I think
there are similar problems about the
claims that human rights come into
conflict with the common good or the
general welfare but they'll put them to
a SATA to one side now now it seems to
me in concluding that there is a serious
danger in the picture of human rights as
constantly in conflict and hence
constantly in need of being traded off
against each other or against other
values the danger is that we lose sight
of the distinctive moral logic of human
rights the logic according to which they
are not merely interests however
important but sources of obligation
obligation whose violation constitutes
our morally wrong even if a justified
moral wrong yet talk of conflicts of
human rights and trade-offs is rife both
in philosophy and in the wider culture I
would especially single out European
human rights lawyers who are influenced
by certain doctrines in German
jurisprudence they identify human rights
violations were ever there's been a
setback
to a significant interest but the
failure to distinguish human rights from
the interests they protect is also rife
a paradigm example is the United Nations
general comment 14 on the right to
health which seems to regard everything
that furthers health as part of the
right to health yet there are all sorts
of things that further the interest in
health that we did not have a right to
because it's impossible to deliver them
or because to do so is excessively
burdensome all this suggests a rather
disheartening possibility that our
widespread commitment to human rights
may be largely ideological
window-dressing more a matter of the
rhetoric of human rights than of
achievement to its reality it's a
possibility we should take seriously so
here I think is something helpful that
philosophy can do it can constantly
remind us of the distinctive
significance of human rights human
rights are not just the shopping list of
everything that is beneficial to humans
lack of rigor about this may in the
short term be an effective rhetorical
ploy when competing with scarce
resources for example if you want the
resources to go to health it helps to
say there's a human right to limb but in
the longer term
lack of rigor threatens to undermine the
discourse of human rights and that
discourse is something we urgently need
to defend we need to defend it in the
face of emerging powerful new states
that do not have a tradition of respect
for human rights we need to defend it
against the new competitor to human
rights the bare insistence on the rule
of law the stripped-down ethic of the
foreign investor above all we need to
defend human rights from their so-called
friends one of the earliest
conversations I had at her
about my project someone asked me what I
was working on I said human rights they
responded how very depressing for you I
hope I hope this lecture wasn't
depressing I actually think of it as
really a message of hope thank you very
much
that was just great
raagh little rites of non toronto right
because that introduces the issue of a
hierarchy of rights but it also
introduces the issue of trade off you
derogate in times of emergency isn't
word and presumably one of the things
that certainly bothers my students much
is what are human rights worth if you
derogate them you trade one set of
rights against a national security
emergency or whatever I just wonder how
you think philosophically about
derogation okay so I find derogation
really quite intractable it's ambiguous
between at least two notions so one
thing you might mean when you say that a
human right is non durog about is that
you can't contract out of it that you're
bound by it willy-nilly okay so this is
one idea that some human rights are used
Kogan's you're bound by them
irrespective of whether you've agreed to
them and you can't contract out of them
another notion of non durability is this
idea that nothing would ever justify not
complying with that right so I take it
that you're saying it's the second
notion of girag ability that you're
talking about um my own view about it is
that something I hinted at earlier that
there's a difference between how we deal
with this in law with from how we deal
with this in morality I have I'm ashamed
to say I do convince myself that there
are situations where I could imagine as
a moral fort experiment that there could
be a sufficient case for torturing
someone in order to bring about a
certain results they've saved the life
of a child by twisting the arm of the
person who knows where the child is and
will die at any moment
and this you in
like this form of torture on them so it
seems to me that you can conjure up
scenarios where morally it's the case
that you would be justified inviolate
you'd still be violating the right and
doing the wrong but that violation would
be justified but I think there's a
separate question an entirely separate
question about whether we should have a
policy of torture that is legally
accepted and whether we should train
people to be torturous and have this as
an official policy of the state I think
there are powerful reasons for saying
that the answer to that must be no so
the same morality that in the kind of
pure case says torture will be justified
says in response to the institutional
question there is a tremendous case for
treating it as a non DeRogatis right and
then you have the other question well
what happens when someone actually does
commit torture in cases that you think
are morally justified but now they're
acting in a way that the law says are
not permissible and I think the best way
to handle this is I think people like
Gallade thomas frank suggested was at
the level of sentencing right but not at
the love of preemptively saying we're
going to identify situations where now
there may be other situations where that
doesn't work but i'm thinking
specifically here of the case of torture
I think it's a separate idea I think so
when philosophers do this for experiment
thing and create a situation for you
where look suddenly there seems to be a
compelling case for violating this norm
they too quickly go to an institutional
conclusion I mean this systematically
happens in philosophy and the point is
no politics law has its own logic
outside of the logic of what I should do
as an individual in this these
particular circumstances
so therefore merely answering that
question that way in that individual
case doesn't begin to address the
question how you should fashion
institutions to respect human rights
who
that's a really great question I really
hated if their inherent conflict I think
they might contingently come up in
conflict in some cases the one thing I
would say is I think there'd be a real
issue of conflict if interests were
subjectively given so if my interests
were simply given by my preferences and
that is how a lot of people under the
spell of economists think of interests
right they think that you fulfilling
your interests if you're fulfilling your
preferences or if they're a bit more
sophisticated your informed preferences
one of the hard core aspects of my work
is I don't accept that view of
well-being or of interests
I have an Objectivist view of well-being
so I think that um what tana me isn't
simply doing what you desire or doing
what you have a preference for me I
think what Onam is about choosing from a
range of valuable options objectively
valuable not simply valuable according
to you so the way I would begin to
respond to that question
the dwarf-tossing one is to go back to
the case of them slavery and someone
says I want to be a slave I'm going to
be paid a lot of money to enter into
this contract of slavery I choose to be
a slave that money will help my family
etc so I want the law to uphold and
recognize this contract of slavery that
I'm entering into and uh presumably we
would say that we're not going to do
that because the proper understanding of
the autonomy we want to protect is one
already influenced by dignity and it's
not a genuine
of autonomous choice if you decide to do
something that in that way undermines
one your dignity and second also
undermines some other form aspects of
your autonomy so I think what you're
suggesting is probably correct that they
might come a point where I'll be faced
with some contingent conflict between
these two elements but I'd like to
forestall that as much as I can by
emphasizing the Objectivist character of
the notion of autonomy I recognize
though that this will make my view
profoundly unappealing to many people
because they think that autonomy simply
is doing what you desire so when someone
desires to rape a small child and we
interfere with that we're in a sense
setting back their interests whereas I
would say no interest of his is set back
when we prevent him from doing this
thing that has zero value factors
massive negative that's a good question
I should have put in disclaimer I really
don't want to do that so I think that
animals have interests I think animals
have dignity
there's the inherent dignity of being a
crocodile according to the Israeli
Supreme Court this is not funny to me I
think it's makes absolute sense and I
think in virtue of that that it makes
sense also to say that animals have
rights
I just wasn't talking about them but
it's a mistake on my part that I didn't
emphasize that because I don't want to
say that I'm human dignity and human
interests are essential for having
rights I just want to say they're
essential to human rights but they're
also animal rights another topic making
me feel not as foolish as I was I could
have discussed that in the book as well
but I should actually have
I really appreciate the question I had a
prompt to myself to talk about this and
I ignored it so I'm really glad to you
raised that some people think that human
rights are immutable rights possess
throughout human history by all human
beings right and that could be an
interesting topic if you're interested
in cavemen
you might wonder you know what rights
did they have but as I said I'm
interested in the practice of human
rights in particular the kind of idea
that was behind Universal Declaration of
Human Rights I don't think that was
about trying to figure out immutable
human rights that have been possessed
throughout human history so I think it
makes perfect sense to say human rights
evolve the rights that we have can
evolve over time and they evolve in will
in as a matter of changes in what's
possible and what's regardless
excessively burdensome technology can
make not burdensome something that
formerly
was burdensome then suddenly we have a
right to this thing the Internet the
previously we didn't have a right to so
I think this is actually a strength of
the view and it matches the way in which
human rights evolved so it's not like oh
well they had mistaken views in the past
and therefore now we have correct news
it could partly be that they had
mistaken view so it could partly be but
circumstances objectively change the
facts about human rights and I think
this is particularly important way of
addressing some of the skepticism that
people have about socio-economic rights
they say well these are just newfangled
rights or not real rights you know in
the old days no one ever talked about
right to work and it's a positive right
to work that someone should be given
work opportunities or a right to an
adequate standard of living but if you
look at that context there was a lot of
sort of little political economic
assumptions that it was simply not
possible to arrange society in such a
way that there wasn't going to be no
significantly poor section of society
people just didn't think that was
possible you know the poor are always
with us was not just the religious
notion it was an economic notion they
believed that and it may for all we know
be true right but part of what happens
at the time is things were formally not
possible become possible but equally it
might be that through climate change and
so forth you may be eventually end up
losing some of the rights we possess now
because the circumstances actually can
deteriorate as well as improve yes we're
at the fact
mattias yes
and it's very hard to see how you would
get that out of an Orthodox theory if
you start with reflective interest and
dignity you to get from there to not
serve not for any kind of relations
oceans about really establish equality
of the stores automatic of the universe
now you can forward a lot of stuff into
notions of interest and dignity model
the clothes that you want to actually
stay to the idea of what to derive from
us being human simply invert your
humanity the clothes that you stayed
without the less plausible it becomes to
get any kind of comparative stuff
without certainly got a carrion
connection so first question about the
second one is I find it actually quite
striking that you emphasize wrongly or
maybe that conceded so clearly that the
task of seeing how we how we get from
interest and dignity to duties it's just
hard because if you I was just being
modest
well from the point the second point the
question is what's the alternative is
there a better account of how we
generate these duties but the other
thing I would really want to stress is
this and I didn't stress this in the
talk there's only so much that pure
moral reasoning can do and it's a
mistake to ask it to do more my big
lesson from Aristotle can pure moral
reasoning tell me exactly how much the
murderer should receive as a just
punishment I think I can't does that
mean that it's subjective no it can tell
me that merely writing him a letter of
strong complaint is not a sufficient
punishment but he could also tell me
that you having him torn limb from limb
by dogs wild dogs is an excessive
punishment there is a range and then
within that range some reasonable range
we need some process of social decision
to pick out what that's going to be so
in a way I made it appear harder for
myself because I was purely talking
about what the situation is from the
perspective of pure moral reasoning but
that's never the situation pure moral
reasoning always has to be supplemented
by social decision whether it's
conventions whether it's law that take
up the slack and what I would say is
this is not unique to human rights this
is across the board in ethics that's why
you need lawyers as well as philosophers
it's not and I really resist them often
this ambition of philosophers to come up
this highly precise moral norms I just
think they're intruding into the area of
social decision that are treating it to
the area that law has to play a role so
I think there is something to be said it
doesn't get you all the way but that's
typically the case in moral reasoning
you often need this extra element to
make more concrete you know it has to be
more concrete there's a moral reason to
make it more concrete but pure morality
won't tell you what that more concrete
outcome will be
you need some social decision well I
think I I wouldn't know how to begin
deriving any duties unless I appeal to
interests and unless I appeal to some
kind of status that people have what
would i appeal to but let me address the
other point about Buchanan and let me
just take a wider angle view rather than
talk about the specific thing you talked
about Buchanan has written a book which
is very interesting it says that
international lawyers and others have
often said well human rights the right
to possess simply virtue of our humanity
it's something like the Orthodox view
and his claim is any adequate account of
human rights surely has to account for
human rights law and that there's no way
in which we can see human rights law as
simply reflecting background
moral rights because he's background
moral rights won't give us anything like
what international human rights law
gives us I'd say that there are two
problems with that
the first is he's got a really mistaken
view about how we generate rights and
the mistaken view is he thinks that
there is a contrast between individual
rights and the common good so if
something's an aspect of the common good
it can't be something you have a right
to but the whole tradition of Aquinas
and more recently finis Rhys doesn't buy
into that disjunction between something
I've got a right to and something that's
part of a common good
so therefore things like the
immunization for diphtheria and so forth
could be things we have rights to even
though they're also part of the common
good but the second thing is this always
in philosophy you have to ask the
question what's the alternative to the
position that I'm putting
because every position has got its pros
and cons so he says what international
human rights law is doing is not
securing pre-existing moral rights its
securing to other things a decent
minimum for people a decent level of
satisfaction of their interests and some
basic notion of status equality now
here's the problem what is a decent
minimum how do i specify when something
is at the decent minimum or above the
decent middle I think the only answer is
something like what point is a duty
generated to all human beings to provide
them with this minimum so therefore his
alternative is not a replacement to the
Orthodox view it just is a different way
of specifying the Orthodox view and
equally if I'm right if I was right
about the point that I could disrespect
so I could have raised the sentiments
that are not rights violations right
then the mere fact that I'm appealing to
stay this equality doesn't yet get me to
human rights I have to talk about a
certain way of violating that status
equality which is violating some kind of
Duty arising from that status he's got
the same problem that I have his
pretending doesn't have the problem by
talking about notions like decent
minimum and stavis equality whereas in
fact we want to what levels of these
what aspects of these are protected by
human rights law not all of them so I
think it's not it's it's not a genuine
alternative to the view that I'm putting
forward